oh no no okay so it goes real [ __ ] up
so you get a rain you get a rain like
day or two later I don't wait to get
arrested and then your first court date
like something like mine's probably I'm
probably in there for like two months
before I get into the actual court date
where I stand in front of a judge I was
talking to my parents I'm like they're
like do you wanna get a lawyer I go no
that was the next ended up going eight
months um
they ended up giving me probation I
forgot how many how long it was yeah so
I get I get out on probation and the day
we got out my mom took him straight to
the Outback Steakhouse for like [ __ ]
like surf and turf in bloom in Ostia and
he's still just like [ __ ] strung out
in there to say say like I [ __ ] hate
everybody this [ __ ] sucks
and then like remember that no no
there's a lot of stuff like I don't
remember huh and I remember very vividly
taking you to checkers to on the one by
gooses that's closed down now around
here and like we're just like in line
ordering spicy chickens and you're still
just like wanting to get [ __ ] up and
you're just like this [ __ ] sucks it
wasn't even my fault as [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're just like you keep like
repeating that same story about like how
it wasn't her fault and how like you
didn't deserve to be in there for that
long and how [ __ ] up it was well yeah
yeah you you go through that layout cuz
I'm [ __ ] up but I didn't [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] right that next [ __ ] I mean
that was that was because of that I mean
that's just kind of how you think you
know anything but all the photos like a
chain reaction all the bad [ __ ] doesn't
mean that leads you to that point right
I mean you [ __ ] what [ __ ] like that
happens you totally deserve it because
you're hanging out with those people
right if you're not you know what I'm
talking about right if you want to let
us know these are [ __ ] scumbags these
aren't like dudes that got their [ __ ]
together these are like total [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] yeah I mean that's what I
was at that time yeah like I didn't give
a [ __ ] about nobody so yeah a lot of
that [ __ ] I don't remember cuz I was so
[ __ ] high like yeah just kind of [ __ ]
like that and then so we keep going like
fast forward kind of just yeah just keep
doing the same [ __ ] get some oh no I
think I tried to I tried to I went to
the doctor and I tried to just sell them
because I had has had this thing about
[ __ ] working I know I'm not like
working yeah
or like being told what to do kind of
deal which was which has been pretty
pretty rough for all the [ __ ] I've
[ __ ] done so yeah just just fast
forward just kind of just kind of felt
right back to like I never went to jail
like nothing ever happened I'm I'm still
getting [ __ ] up just the same there
was a Misha cycle tried smoking crack
shot up crack a lot more than I what was
that like uh I don't know I just shot I
smoked it like once or twice okay I
didn't really like smoking it because I
was like well I'm gonna crack it I'm
just gonna shoot crack smoking it but
it's funny he's just saying it like when
you're that [ __ ] up you just try to be
like well it's hard because like a lot
of people like normal people like well
we summed up least I'm not as bad as
they are but like when you're [ __ ]
doing everything it's like you just
gotta you're grasping on two legs you're
like hanging off a cliff hanging hanging
onto like a piece of grass and that is
like probably the only that is the only
drug I've never done like knowingly like
never bought that never bought Maribeth
I might have done it next to see
I never know I did not inhale what's it
smell like offers you know what that's
like slim jims and stray cats hit a
little bush light kept his Marlboros and
bush
yeah so uh where we going yeah so it's
just the eight months I was out after
after I got out on probation was just
same [ __ ] just spiraling so on I got
arrested that first time on February
25th 2017 on February 25th 2018 I had no
idea it was one year to the date I I had
coke but I didn't do it that night for
some reason which was I never went to
bed with drugs ever you guys finished I
always finished it I could not keep it I
had to go till it was gone so but it was
weird that morning I woke up super early
and I'm like oh cool I'm gonna shoot up
cocaine all day today so but I thought
you had yeah well so wake up with the
bag of your life oh yeah but it's like I
was I didn't have it like a regular like
cuz when you shoot drugs use like an
insulin needle okay it's really small
okay okay
I only think I had was like what you
shoot steroids with like a big [ __ ]
what it's whatever the doctor like it's
like an insulin needle when you're
shooting up regular drugs I mean it's
like that long and it's it's it's it's
like it's like smaller than a [ __ ]
showing needle yeah okay a steroid
needle is like that [ __ ] long and
it's [ __ ] it's pretty girthy really
big one of those McDonald's draws long
and goofy yeah why don't have a lot of
experience with that do you
from your locker takeout for mom or dad
right are you talking about girth they
called you the tunic and jeans
yeah so uh yeah so I mean that's [ __ ]
it's just like your arms are [ __ ]
I was wearing like long sleeves I never
I never got like track marks but yeah I
would just stick them wherever but like
you're just kind of just like got polka
dots kind of all those are pretty
obvious you could see it pretty well
yeah so we're like long sleeves and then
he's always wearing sweaters yeah and I
[ __ ] I never wear sweaters right and
Florida yeah yeah yeah so um I [ __ ]
forgot where we're going with this the
second arrest yeah you all can woke up
with a wake up it's so when I woke up
yeah I mean that's lets years and years
of drug abuse right there thanks bud so
that day I mean I was hanging out with
this chick just like total Pinellas Park
like homecoming queen and they're riding
around just kind of shooting up drugs
and I remember in the seminole mall
[ __ ] bathroom and she's like you got
any more I was like no I'm like I could
do the bathroom and like shoot up in the
bathroom and then something happened I
dropped her off at somebody's house and
then it just kind of hit me all at once
kind of like what are you doing what are
you doing with your life like this isn't
you because like people had no me no I'm
not I mean I'm [ __ ] crazy but I'm not
like that [ __ ] insane like with the
drugs and all that well they knew I was
[ __ ] up with the drugs but they didn't
think I'd really do anything too crazy
so I just kind of I don't know even know
what made me think about it I was just
like I want to go I want to kill myself
but I'm gonna do it by running in a
pharmacy and OD'ing on the pills got a
deal just kind of OD in the pharmacy you
just had the idea at Seminole Mall that
you want to you this was right after I
dropped the girl off I was driving
around I was out of drugs
- which is you're out so you're unlike
the [ __ ] I was out of coke so action
when you're coming down off I mean
it's a shitty feeling and now it just it
just sucks so I'm like oh I'm gonna Rob
running this pharmacy that I used to go
to all the time just just the same [ __ ]
like you could be like eight hey could
you just front me like ten of them till
I get my script on in a couple days and
then how do they would do it kind of
like they're I mean they're all pieces
of [ __ ] - so yeah yeah I didn't really
feel bad about it but um I had but I was
shooting it we didn't have any water
bottles in the car and you shoot like
water and stuff to shoot up so I had an
old thing of fruit punch in my car I
need water uh woody mix it to shoot up
drugs so you mix the cocaine with water
yeah and you put it in the needle that's
a yeah drop that's what makes it yeah
yeah okay that's how you can shoot it so
uh I had I had a fruit punch rolling
around the car I filled the needle up a
fruit punch and I bring in the pharmacy
what the [ __ ] so they yeah it was [ __ ]
dude but so wait if you filled up with
fruit punch why you thought it was blood
no no to make it look like it was like
his weapon going in there with it okay
boy
like how [ __ ] up I got my name
tattooed Omar was my first tattoo when I
was 16 I remember that I ripped my
[ __ ] I don't I think I've ripped a
sleeve it's all [ __ ] up oh this makes
no [ __ ] sense I like ripped one of my
sleeves off and put it over my Jake
tattoo they won't know who I am
however just standing in the pharmacy
and I couldn't pull the trigger I
couldn't do it and then I was about to
walk out I was about to turn around and
just leave and then I'd something just
like totally [ __ ] came over him he's
like no I'm on the [ __ ] we're doing
this and I was it was kind of a blur
from then I remember these two chicks in
there they're freaked out like the guy
that owned it they're like it's in the
back it's in the back so wait you're
standing in the pharmacy like where are
you like oh look in the it's a it's a
small [ __ ] I mean it's just kind of
like okay that's probably the only thing
they ever filled prescription wise was
like opiates and Sheila you know what I
mean yeah kind of deal like that was
back it was back in the day when they
were pumping them all out like that so
uh I was just standing there just kind
of like because they would have like
band-aids and like kind of weird [ __ ]
like that it was kind of like the the
top shelf the Food Mart right by her
house
nothing in it just kind of like you got
some bengay in there look like a real
pharmacy yeah some girl I was kind of
like walking around waiting for people
to leave and then that's that's when
that happened to where I was almost like
walking out and then I just remembered
turning like where where was this needle
the whole time um I probably had it I'm
not sure 100% I probably had I probably
had like in my pocket or something like
okay so then I did I pulled it out I
said were they at and they're like
they're in the back they're all in the
back and I remember going back in the
pharmacy in the little room where they
keep all like the the drugs kind of
locked up yeah so I didn't know where
the [ __ ] they were at and it's just like
you're just like that [ __ ] going on that
too at the same time yeah I think so but
it was just like shitty little [ __ ]
Home Depot drawers that were like locked
drawers yeah so I'm just ripping the
Front's of the drawers off with like
with my hands Qaeda and then I finally
looking for the pill like the holy
[ __ ] Grail like I fell in there the
Fountain of Youth yeah so then they have
one of these big big huge like mortal
mortar and pistols kind of how they
compound the drug powders yeah yeah like
that so I remember taken like three
three bottles of the roxies which is
like a hundred in each bottle and just
dumping them all into this [ __ ] big
thing and [ __ ] just mash them all
just like it's like I kind of wish there
was a video of it because it is so
[ __ ] ridiculous what I did this users
a video oh no you're telling them what
they know they know the deal I just
don't know where's it at where's it at
right instantly no I cuz that's all they
[ __ ] that's already there where is it
that's all they pump out of there and
they do that so they're like it's in the
back Roxie's so they plan to rob them
and get out of there oh my plan was to
go in and kill myself that I be okay so
I get back there and I'm I'm crushing
all these [ __ ] pills up I dumped
water in there I'm trying to [ __ ]
know as nito try to like it's like
wishes they're still kool-aid in the
needle no I
okay yeah that's why because ranked that
first
[Laughter]
that's why cuz I had the one needle and
if it was blood it would've totally like
clogged up yeah kind of deal yeah yeah
because that's another problem when
you're a [ __ ] junkie know about that
what just your needles clogging if
there's blood or something in there yeah
so um so I'm back there and I'm trying
to draw this these [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] I just made into the needles like
soup
but you I couldn't get it it I couldn't
get it oh it's too thicker it's um okay
so when you when you're shooting up [ __ ]
you you put in or whatever like a spoon
or a cap or whatever take your cigarette
filter you pull it out right right right
to filter follow it up and that's how
you filters it to keep all the keep all
the good [ __ ] in there you know what I
mean so uh so you're going no filter
you're just I'm just trying to and I'm
getting mad I'm getting mad at first cuz
I'm like why isn't this [ __ ] I just
want to just end this right now but then
I don't know if something came over I'm
like I kind of snapped out of it to
where I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing and I was like ah there's just
kind of you come to and you're like [ __ ]
man I [ __ ] up really [ __ ] bad and
so I didn't know this at the time but
there was a I think there was a 38 a gun
a handgun in the back in the back room
where I was at I was locked in they
locked you in there they were trying to
call me tell me look like I think that
people that dude that owned the pharmacy
he was like Jake he knew me
oh really mean so he's like told me to
come out I'm just like I don't even know
why the [ __ ] I was answering the phone
that's kind of weird like that like the
lamb called you they call it like I
remember answering the phone no it was
in it was in this back when they kept on
there like and there was a phone there
there was a phone back there and it kept
ringing I I was I don't know why I
answered it
so I'm like he's telling me to come out
and then so there was a handgun in the
back yeah so and then they called the
cops they told him there's a handgun in
the back but I don't know about it so
SWAT team came and you know it wasn't it
didn't take that long for me so at this
point you had given up on on trying to
kill you yeah I kind of snapped out of
it just kind of like
oh man what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
[Laughter]